so now let's talk about school shootings
in 2018 more broadly right we talked
specifically about this shooting over
the weekend in Santa Fe Texas ten dead
ten injured horrible let's talk about
school shootings this year now okay you
will hear from the perverted diatribes
of the gun fetishist right this talking
point that the world is safer than it
has ever been and that's true right when
you're talking about war and massive
conflict and crime rates at large that's
actually true but when they say it to
minimize the problem of school shootings
it is a red herring or they will say gun
deaths aren't really a problem
because a ton of them are suicides or
they'll say it's merely a mental health
issue or whatever debunk talking point
right none of them actually address the
issue of school shootings they all talk
around it to contextualise for you how
bad the problem is I want to give you
just a few numbers that are stunning
because of their vile and depraved
nature first of all the number of
students who have died in school
shootings in 2018 is greater than the
total number of military deaths in the
American military in 2018 okay when you
look as the Washington Post points out
at the fact that there have been more
than thirty students who have died in
school shootings this year so so far of
course parkland Florida and Santa Fe
Texas being some of the worst ones the
worst ones and you see that just under
30 military service members has died so
far and that's by the way if you include
a helicopter crash that one could argue
does not really represent the spirit of
military deaths because the fact it
wasn't really relevant to military
activity in any way but we're still
including it you still have fewer people
killed in the American military in 2018
than students at public schools and
shootings now before you jump all over
me Pat
yes that's getting upset here because
I'm not mentioning something obviously
we need to consider the base rates there
are more than 50 million students in
public schools there are only 1.3
million members of the Armed Forces so
on a percentage basis clearly it's more
dangerous to be in the military it's
about 40 times more dangerous to be in
the military than it is to be in public
school I get that Daniel Kahneman would
be very happy with you right now
yes together remember the base rate at
all times I'm not falling for the base
rate fallacy but the school shooting
numbers are stunning and really
shouldn't it be more than 40 times safer
to be in school than to be in the
military like isn't isn't that number
even disturbing isn't it shocking to
some degree that being in the military
is only 40 times more dangerous than
just being in third grade at public
school and in fact the high school-age
American is 82 times more likely to die
from a grant gun homicide than 15 to 19
year olds in the rest of the developed
world which is flat-out disgusting now
for some other numbers and this is
always shocking when we look at it this
shooting happened Friday May 18th
today is Monday May 21st since this
school shooting including Friday
there have been 185 shootings in
addition to the one in Santa Fe Texas ok
that doesn't even include this morning
and probably there were some shootings
this morning now now all 185 had deaths
or injuries but we had something like
more than 50 people killed and over a
hundred and twenty-five injured in other
shootings just on the day of the Santa
fé shooting and the do two days that
followed this is so crazy
that if you want to I I don't even know
how we wrap our head our minds around
this I really don't at this point the
numbers are of such a scale yeah and if
you think about the reason why people in
the military are so revered and
respected it's because when they put on
that uniform they go overseas and and
fulfill whatever duties are required of
them there's a chance that they could be
killed in action correct and we don't we
don't attribute the same virtues to
those in school like just about sack or
a student yeah and some students sadly
from the Santa Fe Texas school were
interviewed and they said you know we
it's been happening all over we felt it
would happen here another students
saying something like I was wondering if
every day I wonder if today is the day
that there's a school shooting this is
what's going on and meanwhile the idea
is to strengthen the schools so that
they're safer the current administration
has given the military budget a ton more
money and they tried cutting the
education budget so far Congress has
resisted those cuts but that's what they
want to do so I don't know what next I
would say we've got an election in five
and a half months register to vote vote
out anyone
who doesn't support common-sense gun
reforms when it comes to all all of
these issues not just the gun reform but
mental health access education democrats
and republicans similar on many issues
different on many issues last week we
talked about net neutrality as a great
example vote then out it is the only way
quick break I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and we'll be back after this
today's episode is made possible in part
by zip recruiter if you're hiring you
need great people but also a better way
to find them and you need something
better than just posting your job online
and hoping the right people will see it
zip recruiter knew there was a smarter
way so they built this platform that
finds the right job candidates for you
zip recruiter learns what you're looking
for they identify people with the right
experience and they invite them to apply
for your job and these invitations have
really revolutionized how businesses are
finding their next hires in fact 80% of
employers who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just a single day
and that's not all zip recruiter does
they will also spotlight the strongest
applications you receive so you'll never
miss out on a great match the right
candidates are out there zip recruiter
helps you find them and businesses of
all sizes trust zip recruiter for their
hiring needs and right now very exciting
david pakman show listeners and viewers
can try zip recruiter for free if you go
to zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman
that's zip recruiter comm /p a que ma n
tried for free
zip recruiter comm slash Pakman